thank you thank you thank jesus christ
i don't know what you're so happy about
no i mean i know why you're happy
i love it rowdy cracks like the old
arsenio show wow
but uh hey exactly remember that
i love moo-hoo okay that but that's
enough
but uh hey first off we should wish
obama a happy
60th he turned 60 years
on old big day
and you know they they had a huge party
like 500 people played that you know the
movers and shakers of the world and then
they had to scale it way back
because of covid and it just looked too
ostentatious and tough times you know
so now it's like oh jeff bezos had to
self-park his rocket
but no this is turning into quite the
disaster because come on a party for 500
of the top democrats gets cancelled at
the last minute
you know how much leftover baby there is
they think they eat babies no don't the
democrats have bigger problems
i mean this is day four of the andrew
cuomo death watch
have you been following that story the
governor of new york yes the report came
back yes
sleaze
democrats are dropping him like he's
made of gluten no really
he has no friends now biden called on
him to resign nancy pelosi called on him
to resign
uh chuck schumer yes called understand
anthony weiner called for a double date
that's a different kind of guy and over
no i mean
everyone is piling on now over in new
jersey uh chris christie said you know
when i was governor i pulled out my
salami
it was actually my lunch
i wrote ton to man but you know the guy
i feel
bad for chris cuomo i mean cuomo's
brother because he's on cnn he's got to
report the news and this is the news i
mean it's tough
it's like if steve ducey had to report
on his brother
dummer
so yeah now it's they say it's grim at
the governor's mansion there in new york
cuomo is getting
so desperate that uh he's alone in the
mansion screaming all day long i
i bet if i look like gavin newsom they
would have liked it
you